Understanding the Economic Structure in 30 Minutes The economic mechanism
is simple, but there are few people who understand it, and there are many people who cannot understand the mechanism and are
forced into economic wards.
This is an unconventional way of thinking, but over 30 years of proven results, I
was able to foresee and avoid world bard devices
.  So let's get started.
The mechanics of the economy look complicated, but the trick is simple.
It's made up of simple components and simple transactions. And
this is happening over and over again.
It's Human Wisdom Day, and it's going
to keep the economy going, and three main things come out of it:
the first is the growth of productivity,
the second is the short-term smell of
debt.
We can understand economic trends and the situation of zenzai by considering the three elements individually and by considering model cases that stack them.
Let's first look at the simplest element of the economy, transactions
is an accumulation of
transactions Transactions are simple things
We do transactions all the time When you
buy something you get it In a
transaction you give money and credit in exchange for the seller to give you the goods  We
provide services, assets, etc.
Credits are like money, so if you add up the money spent and credits,
you can see the total payment amount.
This total payment amount drives the economy.
Divide the payment amount by the amount of sales
.  Well,
it's part of the economic gimmick.
Economic waves and movements are driven by transactions.
So once you understand transactions, you understand how the economy works
.
For example, the wheat market, the car market, the
stock market, and other markets. The
economy is the sum of all the transactions and all the markets. If
you calculate the total payments and the shipping costs in all the markets, you can understand how the economy works
.
One company bank government agency
all of this is doing the transaction we just talked about
exchanging money for credit goods services assets
the biggest buyers and sellers are government agencies
you can classify this into two central  The government collects Zengin and spends money and  The central bank,
but unlike the ordinary buyer-seller, it can control the growth of money and credit in the economy
.
Let's think about the pre-station The pre-
station is an important factor in the economy, but it's
also the least understood factor.  In the same way that
buyers and sellers make transactions in the market,
lenders also make transactions.
I want to invest.
Credit can help lenders and borrowers.
On the
other hand, if the sibiko is low, the amount borrowed will increase. If the
borrower makes a promise to repay and believes it, credit will be generated.
Credit can be generated by any two people
.  looks simple, but there is a different side to
credit.
So why does credit matter? When
borrowers finish credit, they can spend more
. Quality drives the economy
.
Your spending is someone else's income
. The income you have is someone else's expense, so if your spending increases, someone else's income will
increase.
Because the
borrower's creditworthiness has increased. With
credit, there is repayment capacity and collateral.
You can sell
it, and it gives you peace of mind that if you
earn more, you can borrow more, and you can
spend
more.
This virtuous circle leads to economic growth.  In a
transaction you have to give something to get something, and the amount you get depends on how much you can produce
Accumulation of knowledge raises the standard of living and raises production
Inventory  And workers are more productive and have higher standards of living than lazy people who do nothing.
But this may not be the case in
the short term.  Credit plays an important role. In the
short term, productivity
doesn't fluctuate much, so it doesn't affect the economy much.
But with debt, you can spend more than you produce.
There are two major cycles in debt,
one is the fall of 5 to 8 years, the other is the miasma of 75 to 100 years,
and you can usually feel the movement of this wave.  But you don't realize that there are cycles. Because the
lame movements happen day by day, week by week, it's hard to notice big movements. So let's
take a step back and look at these three big factors and how their interactions affect the economy.
Let's think about whether small
fluctuations in economic trends are not caused by economic revolutions or changes in the employment environment.
The only way we can increase our spending is by increasing our income.
We need to increase our productivity and the number of hours we work. The
economy cannot grow without increasing production.
My spending is other people's income.  If you multiply, the economy can grow. In
this environment, economic growth happens at the same time as productivity growth
.
It also happens with credit volatility based on that.
Throwing money is kind of like front-loading your spending. To buy more than you earn,
you spend more than you earn.
If
you do this, there will come a time when you will have to spend less money than you earn in order
to repay the future.
It's the same for individuals and for the economy as a whole,
so we need to have a solid understanding of credit.
When you create a pre-sit, you create a series of events that are predictable in the future. In
this sense, credit is different from money.
It's produced on the spot, but
if you use credit to buy beer, it creates a desk,
a promise to pay it back in the future
.  The child and the signature later disappear when the bill is paid
[music] The
hunt is over and the deal is made In
reality most of what you think
of as money is credit The total amount of credit in the United States is about fifty  But the total amount of money in circulation is only about
three trillion dollars.
So in a
credit economy, spending is higher and income growth can outstrip productivity
.
It
's not always a bad factor that causes economic fluctuations. What
makes it worse is that even if you want to spend too much, but you can't, it's a good factor when you use economic resources to generate income
and make it possible to pay off
your debts.  But if you sterilize it and buy a tractor and you can
harvest more and sell more, you
can pay off your debt and at the same time improve your
standard of living.  Let's take a look at how credit can create economic growth.
Let's
take an example. Let's say you earn $100,000 a year and have zero debt.
So even if
your
income is $100,000, you can still spend $110,000
.
If a person has no time and has an income of $110,000, then
$11,000 can be placed, and even if the income is $110,000, it will support $121,000.
So it's the same principle, Melco.
But one thing we
must not forget is that even if debt pushes up the economic wave,
how low is that wave? This is the short term concentration of debt.
And then unit debt fluctuations begin, and
then spending increases and prices start to rise,
because the economy was boosted by credit.
If the speed increases, the price will start to rise. The
price rise
will mimic inflation.
Central banks want to avoid this kind of problem
.
The higher the price, the less people will be able to borrow the money, which in turn
increases the cost of existing debt.This means your gift card will pay
more, as
fewer people will borrow and the cost of repaying it will skyrocket.  Ordinary people will spend less.
Spending is someone else's income.
When the problem of inflation gets worse and the problem of inflation disappears, the
central bank tries to cut interest rates and
revitalize economic activity.  It's a gimmick of economic activity. The
main thing that affects the short-term debt cycle is the willingness of lenders and borrowers to accept credit
. When
credit is easy, the
economy grows, and when credit is hard, the economy slumps.
is controlled primarily by the central bank.
The cycle of funk time is about five to eight years,
and this repeats itself for decades.  Compared to the House of Representatives, it's higher and the debt is
increasing.
Why is that?
The sign grows faster than the income, and
this is the long-term debt volatility. Even though
people are in debt, they turn around and try to provide more credit.
Why
?  Because people tend to think that
people pay attention to recent trends,
what's happening these days?
If
this resistance pervades society, it will become a bubble. Even if the
debt is increasing, if the income is increasing by the same amount
, there is no problem with the prefectural debt.
Let's call
it the debt burden ratio. As long as incomes are rising, debt burden ratios are fine. Assets are going up
in value
.  I feel
that even though the debt is soaring, incomes and property values ​​are rising, so
there's no danger in getting credit.
Then the amount of repayment will increase, and the amount of repayment will be faster than income, so there will come a time when
it will increase.
Debt service is still going on, so it's going to be
even worse all the time. There
's a wave of economic fluctuations coming back.
This is the culmination of the long-term debt cycle.
In the United States, Europe and the rest of the world, this happened in 2008. For the
same reason, Japan got angry in 1989
, and it happened in the United States in 1929.
This is how leverage loses momentum.
Credit disappears, asset prices plunge, and
banks suffer. The
stock market crashes, social tensions rise, and the vicious circle repeats itself
.
Credit
will run
out, and you will
not
be able to
borrow money to pay back.  The market will be open to the public, and silver keys will suffer. If the
value of assets decreases, the value of collateral will also decrease, so it will become
even more difficult
to wither away.  This
is a vicious cycle in which it becomes more difficult to withdraw as the output decreases, the income decreases, the value of assets decreases, and the pre-
sett decreases.
In the case of
cake, if interest rates are lowered, the amount that can be earned will increase.
Interest rates in the United States
went to 0% in the 1930s when leverage disappeared
, and they did so in 2008
.
Even if the interest rate is lowered, recovery is impossible.
We face the reality that we cannot repay the full amount
.
The value of the economy has disappeared, and the same
is true for individuals.
So what should we do when leverage disappears?
The burden must be reduced
There are four ways this can be done 1
1 Business Government will reduce Shuori
Debt will be defaulted and restructured
Mr. Saegusa will be redistributed from the wealthy to the rest
And  4
central banks print new banknotes
these 4 really happen when leverage disappears
oops
parker
common room is down first 1
business government tightens purse strings cut spending cuts debt  It's
called austerity, and
we tend to think that when borrowers stop dying and start paying off old debt, the debt burden ratio will go down,
but the opposite happens
because spending goes down and spending goes out to others.  Income shrinks because it's a source of income. Income shrinks faster than debt service
. And the
debt burden ratio
worsens.  Children become
unemployed and unemployment increases.Then
we need to reduce our debt even
more.Many of the borrowers cannot repay their debts
.
People worry about their money in the
bank, they rush to the banks and try to withdraw, the banks run out of business, people and businesses can't pay their debts,
and this leads to an economic crisis
.  It happens when you realize something's gone.
Let's go back to the bar and think about
it.
If you can't do it, Ryo will be in default, and
the bar
's assets will be worthless.
The
contract is canceled in order to reduce the debt, but
I would rather recover some than not pay it off at all.
If this happens, income and asset values ​​will decline rapidly, and the
Saigetsu rate will deteriorate.
And
because unemployment has risen, the government will have to spend more
. Many of the unemployed have no savings and need help from the government.
We are trying to restore the strength of the economy by increasing spending in order to stabilize the economy.
Well,
when leverage is gone, tax revenues have decreased, but the
government's budget burden has increased sharply
.  In order to pay off the debt, we have to either increase tax revenue or increase
debt
, but in this situation where income is declining and unemployment is increasing, where should the tax money come from?
The
wealth is owned by a very small number of people. The
government will increase tax revenues from this wealthy class.
[Music]
Also, the wealthy people hate Kinkonso because of the weakening economy, the collapse of property values,
the increase in taxes, etc. If the
pope continues, social unrest will arise in the country.  Not only is conflict increasing, but
there is frustration between countries, especially between creditor and debtor nations.
In the 1930s,
wars began in Europe and the pope broke out in the United States
.
What ordinary people thought was money actually stood still,
and when credit disappeared, money became scarce. People needed money.
Even the central bank had no choice
but to print money because Mr. Lee
was down to zero.
Central banks print new money out of
thin air, they buy assets, they buy government bonds.
This happened in 2008, during the Great Depression in America.
It printed money, and
other central banks in the world printed as much money as they could, and if you bought financial assets with this, it
would raise the price of those assets,
uh, it would make it easier to borrow, but
this is owning financial assets.
Central banks can only print money, but they can only buy financial assets,
while central governments can buy goods and services and put that money into the pockets of the people, but they can't
buy money.  You can't print it
, so you need the cooperation of merchants to revitalize the economy. The
purchase of government bonds by the central bank is actually lending money to the government, and the deficit budget is used
to fund goods and services.
We're going to increase the income of the people,
increase the national deficit, but this will reduce the total debt burden of the economy.
Maintaining
a balance between deflationary and inflationary factors will lead to economic stability.
When is deleveraging
good? These are difficult times, but if you manage them well, good results are possible.
In the case of , there is less debt relative to income, the real economy improves, and the
problem of inflation disappears.
This is a balance.
By redistributing money and printing money, we can maintain economic and social stability
. People often ask if money will cause inflation.
There
is no difference whether spending is paid with
money or with credit.The central bank will print money and let the extra money be used
to compensate for the declining credit.  More and more, in order to get the economy back on track, the
central bank needs to increase incomes while at the same time ensuring that income growth is growing faster than the interest on the accumulated debt
. What does that mean?
We need income to grow faster than debt,
so let's say we have a country whose leverage is declining.
Let's
assume that this debt has interest. Let's assume Mr. Lee is 2%.
Debt repayment is impossible if you are growing You need to print enough money to make income growth higher than the interest rate
The
important thing is not to print so much money that it causes hyperinflation, as happened in Germany in the 1920s
.
Debt will go down, and
this is possible even if leverage is down. As
incomes rise, borrowers' credit will improve.
If it becomes possible to borrow money, spending will increase and the economy will grow.
This is the revolution stage in the above debt cycle.
It will
take more than a decade for the debt burden to decrease and economic activity to return to normal.
So that's the conclusion.
Of course, the way the economy works is not as simple as we see it here.
We
can understand the current situation, and we can predict the future
. So, to summarize, there are three important factors.
Second
, don't let your income grow faster than
your
productivity, which makes you less competitive. Third, don't spare yourself the effort to increase your productivity
. This is the most important long-term factor.
is a useful example for both you and policy makers. I'm
surprised most people and most policy makers don't realize how important
this is.  I hope so Thank you
[music]